dan fajal likes saying that we're
crickets imagining the big game
yeah exactly right and so that's why
god is actually you know coming from a
kind of scientist who's not a kind of um
a theist or anything like the word the
word god is useful because it points to
the fact that well what does god mean
it's another word but it points to
something utterly
beyond words right utterly transcendent
imminent everything
um and so i actually have a kind of pet
peeve i think in
in kind of spiritual communities when we
use the word consciousness for the kind
of
um for this ground of being because
we're now just
instead of say instead of really sitting
with the fact that the ground of being
is truly
beyond words if we say it's
consciousness then we're kind of it
feels like we
it's tempting to give it a label right
but i think it can get confusing because
i would say
if you think the ground of being is
consciousness then you would think in
that perspective that
at the big bang there was some
experience i'm saying
the kind of ground of being is some
mysterious process and the big bang was
not a conscious event
it was it was unconscious kind of things
happening um
and consciousness exists in these kind
of reflections of living
living systems so it's it's not that
everything is in consciousness in my
world view
um but it's important to understand that
uh
the world isn't divided fundamentally
into matter and mind
everything is processed everything is
just this this kind of strange creative
thing
unfolding which is what we see in
quantum mechanics if you try and say
where is that subatomic particle
good luck it's nowhere it doesn't have a
look at a pre-existing location
because you're part of this kind of web
of co-creation
you know and what we call mata is not
this pre-existing stage it's this
this kind of yeah this process that gets
co-created and
consciousness is also a process and so i
think that's why you can author
scientific theories of consciousness
because all sciences is another map it's
a map of the territory
and we can come up with a map that
describes how matter behaves we can come
up with a map that describes how
consciousness behaves and how they fit
together and i see no problem there
yeah beautiful so we are
constantly trying to make better and
better
maps of the reality
yet the the most simple way to say it
is that there is a an indescribable this
ineffable
um and then there is that
and there's a creative likely
likely an eternal creative
unfolding um and that the unfolding has
a feedback mechanism and the the and
that feedback mechanism
is this this co-creative uh ability
for us to out of all of the infinite
potential that you have as an
artist that you get to pick what you
want to
unfold in the in out of the infinite
potential what you want to collapse
what you want to become so okay so an
eternal
creative process now the the reason why
it's tempting
i think to put to subsume
cosmogeny in consciousness or infinite
consciousness
is because there is
no in a sense nothing else besides
this experience that
we are having and that in a sense
consciousness
is the tool that we use as
from whatever perspective of that god or
source or whatever you want to call that
from that indescribable we use
consciousness as the tool
to experience ourselves
i think my um so maybe my
take on this is that maybe you know it
might be because i'm a scientist that i
i want
the problem for me of of of
consciousness and also just as an
individual who meditates and does this
other stuff
the problem for me is accounting for
this particular thing that is like
it's private it's this qualitative space
of awareness that's here right now and
you have it right
and we're going to give that the label
consciousness and we're going to face
this as a problem like where does that
emerge in nature right
so that's that's one thing if
if all of existence is in consciousness
or it has consciousness or it
is conscious that's it could be a
similar kind of thing but but i think it
won't have exactly the same properties
it pretty much doesn't have like a
boundary and inside and outside
like oh yeah so oh yeah it's yes
it could be something related but we so
we
you know we could come up with a
speculative or metaphysical idea of of
the infinite consciousness
but then there's organism consciousness
yeah yeah um and we're gonna talk about
those differently right oh interesting
okay so as uh you know rupert spyra
talks about this and bernardo castro
does as well there's
the screen the infinite screen of of
consciousness or awareness
and then on it is all of the
all these little perforated like
dissociative
um private uh consciousnesses
and that uh organism consciousness as
you said
and uh i like i kind of like that you
know if we were to make some sort of a
division of this one into two it would
be interesting to do it like a
a metaphysical consciousness that's
indescribable and then like a little
private or organisms consciousness in
the whirlpools
that's kind of interesting yeah okay and
that that kind of takes it from a
scientific side as well it
and i i yeah yeah which is very
important i i agree with this
uh process i i totally agree
i i've lived too um much
in san francisco and
the bay areas it's like spiritual as
community
where there's a very strong tendency
to um kind of just go with whatever new
age
impulse arises and that it's
it's very important to um
both embody whatever that intuition is
but also
embody the science that comes along with
it so
yeah yeah i mean i think for me
it's again it may be uh yeah i you know
if i spend my whole life in science this
might be just an interesting difference
between
you know putting uh our environmental
factors might be
what's what's kind of bringing up our
differences um
yeah our differences on this on this
topic and um
i do think there's a kind of
fundamentally like i
i guess i i've always been fascinated by
kind of
describing uh these things as part of
nature you know nature is this like
yeah it's almost like spinoza had this
idea like nature is god effectively like
it doesn't need to be a personal god
with like
anything like that but it's this it's
just this lawful
beautiful like thing that's that's
that's far bigger than us and so that's
my kind of
my scientific perspective is like when
it comes to this kind of speculative
metaphysical consciousness that might be
bigger than my
home consciousness um i guess i i kind
of
have to i i you know i i don't i guess i
draw the line there for myself as and
say my job as the kind of spiritually
engaged neuroscientist is to think about
this consciousness but i can't i can't
speculate
about that stuff as much but also it's
because
my spiritual worldview is is also like i
you know in like something like the dao
di ching like you know
it's it's all about how
you know the doubt that can be named is
not the eternal dao it's like the
if you're going to try and describe this
thing by calling it anything
if you think you've got a handle on it
you're fooling yourself it's it's
so utterly beyond you know we can call
again metaphysical consciousness or
absolute infinite consciousness this
this is starting to get a vibe that it
sounds very big it sounds very grounded
it sounds like it's the right kind of
word
but then you have to realize that it's
going to be utterly
it cannot encapsulate the ground of
being like so i i quite like
the spiritual side of me just likes to
kind of come up against this mystery
and say like yeah like i don't i can't
know what this
thing is i think it's unknowable in its
essence
um and then the scientist in me is like
okay do i think there's a reason to
think the big bang was conscious of
itself no i can't see any kind of
mechanism by which that would happen so
i'm gonna suspect no and that's when you
start to get into the
these kind of fascinating questions of
like what we might call organisms level
consciousness
which i guess i'm just calling
consciousness um yeah
this is so beautiful because it's
so extremely important to embody
the truth of mysterianism and the idea
of the eternal dao that can be named as
the dao that can be named is not the
eternal dao the idea that
the more that you both truly
surrender to the essence of the
nature of reality both very important
but
also simultaneously balancing
that with the true
scientific spiritual inquiry
into what actually that is and like
you know eric weinstein calls it you
know the source code or and you know
really uncovering what that what that is
and
um you know hilbert talked about the the
importance of
of of uncovering that like we must know
and you know whatever you know boom was
so focused on
uncovering whatever the implicat is and
like
we must know and so it's like this
balance between we must know
and and and probing at it with the
mysterianism
yeah yeah yeah i think i'm a big
advocate for
kind of reigning science in and putting
it in its place when it comes to you
know i
i think that um you know fundamentally
we're humans we're here we're having a
weird experience of
of existence and you know all of the
kind of
the feelings of awe and meaning and
stuff that's the first stuff that you
experience then a scientist might come
along and say okay let's try and do some
clever tricks to come up with good
stories that fit the world
and we do that game and i fell in love
with that game i think it's wonderful
um you know it clearly is it works very
well it's what's allowing us to talk
now yep um so it clearly gives us some
kind of knowledge
but it doesn't eradicate just this
immediate felt conscious sense of
here we are and spiritual experience
right this is for me is like the
spiritual experience
of of meaning and all and and just
existence comes first
and then science is this quite should be
this humble storyteller it should be
something that you know and i guess i'm
i'm describing science here as
i would say science and philosophy like
if you're going to make claims about the
world
try to do it as carefully and vigorously
and and uh honestly as possible
yeah and i think and i think that's why
i actually i'm very happy to stop
very stop short and say what is the
nature of
of the kind of ground of being i don't
have any tools for that i haven't got a
microscope to look at it i haven't got
philosophical tools to think about it um
and so i think i maybe stopped short
further shorter than other people would
in
in speculating about what what it could
be and and yeah that's that's just the
place of
it's recognizing our limits as these
kind of naked apes that came up with
these funny ways to figure out the world
i would also plug here sri aurobindo and
the mother mural fossa talk a lot about
the super irrational enigma that that it
truly is
and that it really does require a
when when you use the body itself
as the mechanism to intuitively tap into
the nature of reality there is going to
be better and better ways to
scientifically
analyze the biometric correlates of
these sort of
awakened states and that's going to be a
very interesting way
for example when someone has
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
and that's a sign of living in the
infinite that's a sign of being god or
the dao
that's a sign of being truth and
butterfly affecting it out
and that's a very you know spiritual
statement and scientists would be like
what do you mean by that let's do that
more
and i'm like yeah we can we can totally
play that that's that's very important
we must plant flags beyond the edge of
knowledge and we must and this is what
you know richard feynman so many other
scientists have been doing this forever
is planting flags beyond what's known
and then in a sense
hypo making a hypothesis and then
testing it which we are
we are going to do now but the vedic
rishis 5
000 years ago parmenides and heraclitus
we're talking about guys that knew
and girls that knew the nature of being
at its most fundamental level by
leveraging
what is just existence phenomenological
awareness
as what they believe to be that true
nature of of of who we are and and i
think that
i think that we must we must realize
that
science is that incredible
tool set that that is very important to
making a map and to understanding um
enabling incredible things like this and
then
to also um enable the other
tool to to help which is in a sense this
spirituality this like we like we
we the we can't
we can't choke the god
in man along the way um we have we have
to
enable the god and man to flourish at
the same time
i want to ask this this question this
has been a
a great back and forth there i really
liked how we talked about
some sort of a if we were to break it
into two
this like metaphysical first principled
consciousness with this
organism consciousness i think that's a
very interesting
way to to break that um down